jf lawton had been writing screenplays
and trying to break into hollywood for
years do you think that would have
happened if he hadn't met you
my belief is that jf lawton was so
profoundly talented i see this in a
number of people in front of and behind
the camera that eventually i have to
i hope and believe that he would have
made it
but one of the things i would say is
at the time i was more manager than
producer when i met him lit
manager and
you're right he had you know he was
living in a one-room studio apartment in
the rampart district of hollywood back
then a very let's just say colorful if
not dangerous
uh experienced on a day-to-day basis and
he had dropped out of film school
and i'm not sure if i've shared this
before but he the way we met was i had
bought one of the early macintosh
computers and
a screenwriter friend of mine was
working on one but you couldn't just
plug them in and work on them someone
had to program them
and i said how did you make it work and
they said hire jonathan so i did
three weeks in my office full time
around the clock
asking me every question about learning
everything that i did and me suggesting
these are the kinds of programs that i
would need
and he was really brilliant and really
lovely but he was quiet
but i became fond of him over the three
weeks and in
some conversation toward the end i
started asking him more questions
and i learned that he was earning his
livelihood
in two ways one he was beta testing
software and writing up articles in
these computer magazines
he was installing computer systems for
film a lot of entertainment companies
on the one hand and on the other hand he
was
late at night editing trailers for the b
movies that came out of canon pictures
back in the day
well when i learned that i thought well
so clearly you have an interest in the
entertainment space and then i found he
had gone to film school
he let let me know he had written seven
scripts that were sitting in a stack in
the corner of his studio apartment that
not a single human had read
his father was a an author an
academician a real a man of letters so
jonathan came by it naturally
so to answer your question
um
when we met
i read about several of his scripts
and i said you're really you're you're
talented rather than refer you to an
agent i want to work with you
but these scripts are as good as they
are and as much as they evidence your
talent they're a little bit quirky
um and what i would like to
have as a means of introducing you in a
meaningful way to the community
because we all live in a steady diet of
hope and expectation that we're going to
discover the next great voice the next
great project the next great artist
that's a critical energy
and so i wanted to be able to frame him
in a certain way and have a certain
quality of screenplay
and
so i asked him i said i want to work
with you but it's not a condition but i
would really like it
if you would create onspec a new
screenplay and i would like that
screenplay optimally to be a romance
i don't care if it's a comedy or drama
and the reason i chose that is because
when you learn about someone's personal
story
you can zero in on things
and in his instance
he was 23 at the time quite young
and he had been in a relationship
he met a young lady when he was 18
and they'd been in a five-year
relationship and he was still madly in
love with her as she had just left the
relationship
to say that he was
sad would be an understatement
and not to be masochistic but honestly i
thought who would write a better romance
at this particular moment
than this young man
so i asked him to give me a romance and
i said just a classic two-hander good
male good female rule
no exploding bridges nothing expensive
like if i needed to make this very
inexpensively independently
we could do that
and that's so he went away and he came
back and it wasn't long i don't remember
i would say
two and a half months
with the first draft of what was then
called 3000 the
script that eventually got transformed
into pretty woman
from drama to comedy
and
without question it was the single most
refined first draft i think i've ever
had held in my hand
uh it was really compelling
and i knew as soon as and i decided it
was so good i wasn't there i gave no
notes
and i started to introduce it very
selectively
and the feedback was so
consistently
um
to say enthusiastic would be in there
people were wowed
so i knew we had
the calling card we had the the welcome
mat to introduce him to the
to the larger community
so i think given given his talent
he would have gotten there i think i
gave it a nudge
um
and
and that was my sort of specialty was
knowing how to present and introduce
someone new to the business
so together i think
we we accelerated the process
what a wonderful story what year was
this
um
i'm going to say it was right around
1984.
oh wow okay
i believe
interesting wow so you saw in him this
sort of reserved
maybe genius but just needed some
nudging and you wanted to see several
scripts of his correct before you
actually made a commitment he reminds me
that what i actually said to him was let
me read one of your scripts and if i
like it i'll help you find an agent
which was a very genuine
comment on my part i would would have
been happy to do so well as it turns out
i read one and then i said this is
really
interesting do you have another
and he gave me another
i ended up reading three
unbeknownst to me he was being very
i would say intentional
because he was giving me
these scripts in the order in which he'd
written them so they kept getting better
and by the third i said you know
jonathan
let's you and i collaborate
i'd like to represent you i'd like to
work with you
and he was delighted and that was the
end of the conversation other than you
know what next
um
so yeah we we we had an extraordinary
uh rapport
and um i would say that he
people bandy about the word genius quite
casually i would say he was
he was quite
he he was what would be my definition of
a creative genius
um
and then and then of course the next
project
that he wrote on spec
was a result of a lunch that we had
together
and the more i dug into finding out who
he was and what his life experience was
his family life and all of that i
learned
that he had been he had done he'd been
in the military i've never been in the
military so to me that's a very alluring
world it's sort of a
fascinating world to me
and jonathan had
served in the coast guard reserve
and he did that
he was in active service at the time
that the olympics were about to come to
los angeles which was many many years
ago i have no idea what year that was
uh probably the very early 80s i would
think
and um i started to ask him about
what was that tell me what what did you
do what where did you serve were you on
him i called it a boat it was a ship
right
uh and he he just sort of regaled me
with these stories of what it was you
know
and they had received counter-terrorist
training because of the olympics so they
had a very intensive program
and the more he talked the more i leaned
in i was absolutely riveted by it
at which point at the end of the lunch i
said jonathan i needed
i need you
would you be willing to write a story
set in that world
and that was the story that was the
foundation for under siege
and that's where he learned his i.t
skills
was was in in the coast guard did they
did they introduced pardon me
um
i don't i don't know if that's a true
statement i really don't okay
yeah fascinating and did you see where
he would write his scripts in this
little
apartment off rampart i saw his
apartment and
he was on the ground floor
the front corner of the building with
windows facing on the alley he was right
on in on the alleyway oh wow and the
visual tapestry on a day-to-day basis
was
um
i i don't want to characterize i don't
want to judge it but it was a constant
parade
of police and working girls and drug
dealers and pimps and homeless etc
and it was because of the part of town
he was in that was it that was just the
way it was on a
persistent basis
so as a backdrop to the original script
that was 3000 it was like almost like
the perfect input right it was because
the original was
uh
you know everyone say oh it was very
dark well it was it it was darker and it
was edgy but you know it's not like
people died and you know it was
but it but it it refl i believe it did
reflect the world he was actually living
in at the time
fascinating very fascinating
thinking back
without jf lawton
how would you attribute your success had
you not met him had it not been the
right time
how do you see your career being
different
um
well i'm eternally grateful for having
met him
um and we did accomplish a great deal
and and not everything that we did of
course got produced as is the case for
everybody but
i was really fortunate i i came without
filters i came from san francisco from
being a criminal defense lawyer
i had
a burning desire to be in the film and
storytelling business the visual
storytelling business
but i didn't have the knowledge to back
it up i didn't have mentors i didn't
know anyone in l.a when i moved here
so i was sort of like this blank slate
just a big white canvas
and um so my my mission was to befriend
and just chat up
anybody and everybody and make as far as
i'm concerned the world i wanted
everyone in the world to be my
five-minute mentor
and then i started you know i made the
decision to open a literary uh shang
hang a shingle as a literary manager
and rented the offices got the furniture
and got the assistant got all the the
attributes of it and i remember sitting
one day
looking at the phone on my desk with my
feet up on the desk staring at the phone
for hours and it never once rang and i
thought oh i've forgotten something
i don't have a plan and i don't have a
network
and i got busy and one of the
things that was at the top of the totem
as a priority was i need i need to find
great people as clients
that said i was so new that i wasn't
sure i
i would recognize what you know other
than we're all great judges
as humans of a good story but in terms
of the structure and how it's crafted
and all of that i was still learning
but i thought okay i'm gonna i'm gonna
use the
my best sense to figure it out but at
the same time it's really important to
me that i find people that i find very
attractive as souls as as artists as you
know like there's a
there's something really wonderfully
unique about them
and i was fortunate to sign his clients
i didn't actually sign in fairness
that's not true
i never had agreements
my you know my philosophy was very
simple
i had to earn my keep every day
i would work hard every day representing
someone in in an effort to launch make
their dream a reality
and on their side of the bargain they
had to work with every bit as hard not
just writing
but
making themselves known as best they
could creating their own relationships
right on a parallel track
and i did sign i did so i keep saying
sign but i didn't
so it was a handshake any time they were
dissatisfied they were
welcome to leave
but i had a lot of very long many year
enduring relationships
and it turns out that several of them
jonathan was not the only great success
story there were quite a few
um
you know alison burnett's done
his written been produced 15 times he's
produced a few of those he's directed
several of those
you know matt reeves um
and his then writing partner
gosh they had
minimal resume
they had some
but matt's going on to direct you know
and produce and write were for the
planet of the apes he did the one before
that i forget the name of that franchise
or that episode
uh he's doing the next the batman that's
coming out next year
so there's a number of these people that
started out with me
that were really quite
you know they were wonderful people and
they were truly gifted
not all of them but quite a number of
them went on to have
what i would call meaningful enduring
careers
what was the original version of pretty
woman the original version was titled
3000 spelled out which was the number of
dollars that edward pays vivian for her
companionship for the week
um
it was a drama it was not a picture
where boy and girl end up together
um and um
in in in some ways it was a much more
realistic story
um
and i think it was very reflective of
the writers sort of
the world that he lived in and the way
he was feeling about things at the time
um
but there was something undeniably
here's what i would say about it
jonathan
when he was in film school
he kept writing these very complex
really interesting leading women
characters
and i remember one of our early
conversations before we started working
together he let on that one of his
professors presumably a male as i recall
wagged his finger at him and basically
said you know leave that alone let the
women write women characters you focus
on blah blah
which was like waving a red flag in
front of a bull
uh john one of the things i'd say that
we shared in common was a certain
reverence for
women
and
that showed up in all of his scripts no
matter how fl and they were all flawed
but they were absolutely magnificent
and one of the things i would say about
his character his women elite lead lead
women characters was that they were
inevitably the moral superior in every
given any given story
and i would say that was one of the
things that really stood out for me
in this sort of
grittier world of hollywood
uh or the collision of these two worlds
the investment banker from new york and
the girl from the streets of hollywood
coming together
this unlikely duo
where he had a certain wound a certain
skepticism a certain you know agenda
based on his relationship with his dad
and his life experience
his current girlfriend
and then she
despite her circumstances
was
this ineffable spirit who had this sort
of moral code
she was just a delightful character
um
who's making the best of her
circumstances
and
there was something so alluring to me
about
her
in this original script 3000.
so while it didn't end well i just saw
that the relationship and who she was
was such an
unexpected
construction
and i uh so i i i i i figure i'm like a
really good audience i'm like
i am almost like the perfect audience to
read a script
i i don't read it when i get a script i
never read it as if i'm the producer
i try not to read it as up on the
director or the financier or the
distributor or any of those hats
um the closest thing i would say is i
try to read it as if i'm going to be the
lead actor
um but more importantly i try to read it
as if i am the audience
because that's ultimately who i am
right
and that script was
was i i
i a must-see story for me
so my belief in it was a thousand
percent it was like it wouldn't matter
how many no's i heard that was going to
be i was going to do anything possible
to get that film made and originally it
was
intended to be made as as scripted as a
lower budgeted you know several million
dollar independent film
because it was set in just a room in a
hotel
right we we didn't have a lot of
production value to worry about um
but
the
i guess the the authenticity of both the
lead characters
was so
undeniable
uh it was written like he knew these
people deeply
and then the supporting cast
jonathan had a gift as well
there's no such thing as a secondary
character they may be supporting
they may not have a lot of dialogue or
page count
but no one in that story is not
important
so the hotel manager even the elevator
opera you know
even before it became a comedy you could
see
these we were witnessing with and
through the eyes of these people and
they were so interesting on their in
their own right
so it was um
i don't know if that answers your
question but it was absolutely
a mesmerizing read
how obsessed were you with the
screenplay when you first read it i wish
i could take it back to the moment i
closed the script cover because i was i
it was a script that i
um
i know that if i can't stop reading
which i didn't i read it cover to cover
in one sitting
which is not that extraordinary but
but it's a good sign
but i know when i closed the screen
cover i was speechless like i had just
experienced something
probably the most special script at that
young juncture of my career that i'd
read to date
um
and i could see it it's it's
there's something about a brilliant
screenplay that draws you and it takes
you on a journey that is so detailed and
and emotive
uh where the characters are so different
or unexpected
um
that you feel yourself literally being
pulled into the story
and
um
that was the case with three thousand it
was certainly
i was i was devastated at the end
but apart from the being devastated
because of the reality of the story and
the experience of the characters
when i closed that script cover
i was a bit stunned into silence like i
know i have a movie i for the first time
you know i
this is like i want this to be a movie i
produce that's the first time i said
that to myself
um
and um
i i don't really you know honestly it's
almost like you go blank after that and
i don't remember all the particular
conversations that we had but i know i
immediately reached out to jonathan and
said i am so happy we're working
together
this is this is a special script scripts
are fascinating creatures and sometimes
there's something that really stands out
it might be a particular character it
might be the world it might be the
descriptions it could be dialogue it
could
there was something about 3000 where the
whole of it was just right
and all of it drew me in
what was interesting was when i finished
reading it i was so excited and yet i
was also very pragmatic i realized i was
still relatively new in the business
um
i mean certainly i hadn't
produced
um except for a couple of micro budget
little you know but i hadn't produced
anything the world knew
and jonathan was still relatively
unknown he was not yet an established
name
but what i held in my hand merited
a lot of attention and the question was
how do i get from here to there how do i
create that energy
and the one thing that occurred to me
was
i think this is such an artful
compelling beautifully crafted story
that
it lives at the level of
the early
like extremely rarefied atmosphere that
was
sundance institute
so i called up
i had befriended michelle satter who was
you know sat at the right hand of robert
redford since day one building the
institute building the festival and all
of
all that it had become and they had all
these beautiful
labs and workshops and they had one
called the production lab
where they would pick i don't know a
limited number eight ten perhaps
projects and invite them once a year
it was maybe a week-long event
and you would go to utah
and you would workshop
the project meaning you would have a
level talent show up uh all these
resource people would show it for free
editors cinematographers actors you name
it
and so you would take that script and
break it down and you'd start
videotaping scenes with these actors
and sort of trying to you know
find what's working how to improve it
etc
so i sent it to michelle and she
um
quite quickly called me back and said i
want this project i want you i want to
invite you guys to
come as the writer producer so we did
and um
it was one of those exalted
moments that you'll never forget because
when you're
still relatively you know you're you're
at the lower end of the ladder you're
climbing the ladder and then you're
invited to sundance already amazing
but beyond that
one day i remember i could i see the
scene i'm sitting there and there are
actors and there are the video cameras
and jonathan's there and
a bunch of other people and we have
these wonderful actors playing edward
and vivian
and we shot a scene and suddenly uh i
hear a voice whispering notes in my ear
what if
and
i look just like i thought i was
dreaming this man
that was whispering in my ear was paul
hirsch
editor of star wars editor of you know
an oscar winning you know like 50 of the
greatest films ever
and he
is offering me creative notes
it was like i died and gone to heaven
it was
a magical experience to see this sort of
come to life in that
venue
and
of course hollywood took notice that was
the whole idea well one of the inciting
ideas was i want people to i want this
in the trades i want people to see that
by association this is a quality project
and that and it worked
the phone started ringing people were
very interested it started to have this
sort of create this this cause celeb
this buzz this
energy um
the script had a consistent it's been
taught in film schools it had that sort
of consistent response
it was one of those rare scripts that
sort of hits everybody where they live
everyone can relate to the humanity of
this story
and
[Music]
um so we were very blessed that way and
that you know obviously like every film
it travels a very twisted journey and it
goes off the cliff here and it dies by a
thousand paper cuts over there and and
so on but you stay with it and
um
i don't know if i've ever shared the
i sent it
wide option to best run and then i got
it back out and then i optioned it to
new regency and we were still stalled we
couldn't get it financed or cast
richard had richard gary turned the
project down
and
during that time back when i was at best
run i had
friends mark and scott who produced
mystic pizza which is just such a
brilliant film
and when the lights came up of this
little friends and family screening to
get feedback before they locked picture
i had i had no criticism to offer
but i saw this girl on the screen and i
said i i don't know who she is but will
you introduce me and that was julia
roberts
and they did they were very kind and um
julia and her then manager read it and
was attached for three years before we
actually went into production
but unexpectedly because hollywood is
nothing if not
non-linear right
it's full of surprise so i sent it to
someone i had known when he was a junior
a lesser executive somewhere and then he
became a senior vp at touchstone
and i sent it as a writing sample
saying this is not disney material it's
about a prostitute
but you're going to absolutely flip
you're going to fall in love with the
craft this writer is someone you need to
know and we're going to come in a week
hence you'll read it we'll come in next
week and we will pitch you
a couple of more disney appropriate
stories
and it was only several days before the
phone rang and
and the call was
we want to buy it
and i was taken a little back
i said gosh
we talking about the same script
well we were and um
i mean there's a there's a lesson in
this for everyone in this business like
you cannot know what's happening behind
the curtain you don't know
all the forces or influences that are at
play
disney touchstone in this case had a
the wonderful project what about bob
and it was going in depression with gary
marshall directing and diane critten and
casting in the full laura siskin line
producing and they had the full team
and at that time michael keaton was the
lead actor
well the deal went awry i don't know the
details but the deal went awry so
production was sidelined
and
they thought gosh we have gary we have
this team assembled
and they looked at our script and
thought great
we'll create a marriage
so there was this meeting a week later
that was no longer a pitch meeting it
was about
we want to buy this script
and we just want to know can you lighten
it
the question actually from the president
of the studio was
on the disney lightning scale this is a
foreign we'd like it to be a seven can
you do that
and i answered absolutely yes we can do
that
um
because it was pretty evident what they
were asking
and
as a result we not only inherited
i i mean
i i'm not so brilliant that i would have
thought of gary marshall directing this
particular film
and we were fortunate because i'd never
had a big studio a major director and a
deep pocket so i went back to richard
gere's agent ed lamato and said please
because ed loved the project
would you go back to richard now
and the studio backed it and they made
him the sort of the godfather offer that
you couldn't refuse
and so richard finally said yes
and the beauty of that was they've been
auditioning and meeting and screen
testing
many many many actors
both for the male and female lead
and
you know it's it's there's sort of a lot
of
it's it's public information there's you
know the long list of name actors and
actresses who who who sort of paraded
through
um
and fortunately many of them declined
um
either passed on it or
whatever for whatever reason it didn't
happen
but julia was not on their radar she was
like an unknown actress
at the time
[Music]
she had shot steel magnolias but it
hadn't come out
uh and she was so you know mystic pete's
a wonderful movie but she was not yet
sort of
well known to either the public or or
the studios
but now with richard
if you have your anchor tenant right
then it was like okay now
uh this is possible just maybe i just
wanted them to screen test together that
would have been all my dream right
and uh so
i you know
i
lobbied and said you know this is but it
had to be gary marshall
and the idea was gary meet her alone
just the two of
you and
you're going to fall in love
and that happened
so when gary marshall versus gary
goldstein says to the sea suite of
hollywood of a major studio
this is my girl i want to screen test it
happened and once they did it was
it it was so undeniable
so the journey of a film is so uh
unknowable so unpredictable
and that we ended up with our dreamcast
and it turns out a dream director i
didn't know what was even in my dream
uh is
it's you know it's the stuff that you
can't
you can't make up
just happens
so 3000 was initially in a kind of a
one-room
scenario maybe a hotel room it was in a
hotel
um very simple locations
um
you know it's all a little bit of a
jumble if i had to go back and parse
what was this piece there or that piece
there but fundamentally the the bulk of
the
the bulk of the original story took
place in
a very limited environment you know
there was a car there was a street that
was a hotel it was not
extravagant
and so once it went to the one producer
or the the head of the studios they said
can you lighten it up on a disney scale
this is a four we need a seven
and so then you added these side
characters and maybe well the characters
most of the characters were there there
was the hotel manager there was kit the
best friend there was an elevator you
know a lot of the
a lot of the infrastructure if you will
was there but it did get expanded there
wasn't a big party scene perhaps there
wasn't you know there were certain
things that didn't exist
or that were dressed up shall we say
you know i don't i don't remember that
we had quite so
showy um a sequence on rodeo drive that
sort of thing
um so yeah it it it definitely evolved
um the beautiful thing was you know my
my my job was clearly to discover and
and launch and protect
great young writers
and i knew that
when we were
having that conversation with disney
um that it was really imperative so the
only the only condition i really had was
uh not about story
it was really about protecting jonathan
and the condition that we put on it was
he has to be guaranteed the first
rewrite
because i had such faith in him that he
would break the back of this and turn it
exactly into the proper you know the
like the best version of its comedic
self
um
knowing the the and this isn't um a
negative it's just
to be expected the studio would bring in
other writers
um jonathan had no
never been produced he wasn't well known
and so
uh he committed the first rewrite we
delivered the first rewrite and long
before it was delivered i was getting
calls from agents saying gary you know
they're reaching out to us for our
clients for you know
potentially hiring our clients for
to do a rewrite and i said i know it's
okay thank you for letting me know but
it's absolutely you know to be expected
and they did there were three other
writers who came in
and
um uh the first one i i won't mention
the name because i was not a fan of the
work at all it was uh
unnecessarily
um
it was actually surprisingly dark and
i wasn't a fan of the writing
but they brought in another writer bob
garland who was from the electric
horseman wonderful new york based writer
and he polished up all the business
dialogue that was sort of his mission
and the final writer barbara benedict
who was a beloved and you know very
sought after script doctorate
came in and did the final
rewrite
and i would describe her work as
bringing it back as close as possible to
the rewrite jonathan had delivered to
the studio sort of brought it full
circle
um
yeah we were very we're very fortunate
this the you know the integrity of the
script was in full tact uh there was a
fair amount of
you know gary marshall is
he had that
gene that magical gene
of
finding the heart of everything that
he
i mean his legacy is so profound both in
on the big and small screen right he
just had that gift
and um so our our arrangement with him
was yes we're shifting this from a drama
to a comedy but you know we're doing it
quickly and we're moving and so once one
take is scripted and then improv and
which was consistent with his style he
gave his amazing directory to watch you
learn a lot watching gary marsha what
when i got to watch him work um he gave
enormous freedom
to everyone on the set not just the
talent
he invited participation at every
conceivable level
he gave actors the freedom to riff and
um
and and you know find the moment
and
you know
lean into it if you will
so it was it was an extraordinary
the set was a really really exciting
place it was a small small budget by
studio standards we were way way down
that register
um
and there was a lot of freedom because a
we had gary marshall b we were such a
small budget they weren't paying the
kind of attention that they do to some
of the bigger films um but it was a it
was a truly wonderful time
so that one connection at the sundance
lab
kind of led to
it how did you how did it's forgive me
i'm sorry her name one more time
michelle satter michelle satter okay
sorry about that um how did you know
michelle
i'm not sure how i originally met
michelle it might have been through some
of her staff for being at sundance i
used to go every year to the
in the early years to the sundance film
festival
uh so i don't really
my memory doesn't stretch back that far
but uh michelle was someone that as soon
as i met her i just recognized this is a
wonderful person and really frightfully
smart
and
um and and i've always been incredibly
grateful because you know in fairness
sundance did i i don't think they really
got the proper public acknowledgement
for the role that they played in the
evolutionary development and the
possibility of that particular film
interesting but it was but it was a key
moment certainly it brought it it
brought it to the forefront of people's
attention
what were some of the lowest moments you
faced
trying to get pretty woman made or 3 000
made whatever evolution it was at
oh gosh
every film has its
peaks and valleys sometimes the valleys
outnumber the peaks
or so it seems at the time
if i look back and think
from the time i held a first draft
script in my hand at the time we were
actually
shooting a film it was only three years
and in the timeline of many films that's
not very long it's actually quite
wonderful
um
but during that time there were moments
when it seemed you know when vestron
declared they were going into bankruptcy
uh that was uh uh you know there was a
lot of strain because if the script was
if we didn't get a turnaround on it if
we didn't actually paper and buy out the
script
uh get it back uh it would have been
buried forever
that's what happens when you go into
bankruptcy right it gets locked up
so there was a lot of i was i was really
concerned about the project at that
point
that when we optioned it to new regency
i wouldn't say there was a low point
there was a frustration
uh not anyone's fault but it's not
always easy to put films together and
get them on track toward production so
it got stalled
and
so that would be more frustr frustrating
over a sustained period of time than it
was upsetting
or a low you know
a low point
um
richard
i was so convinced that richard was
right for this
that when he said no to the project
uh which happened as i recall both at
vestron and then when we were for some
reason i had this crazy idea that when
we're at new regency we should offer it
again
new environment
uh but his same reaction
um
and i understood it richard's a
wonderful you know super educated
professional great i mean he's
fabulous
um but he is a sophisticated and he has
a
a different taste you know being
the guy in a romantic comedy wasn't
necessarily the high point of his
you know
on his wish list it was
almost contrary to the things that he
was most attracted to edgy darker more
sophisticated projects
so there was no surprise there um
the surprise was that he we we
eventually succeeded in getting him
but i would say um
another low point might have been when
we first
were setting that we we set it up at
disney
and i saw all of the people cycling
through perhaps the lowest point for me
i should have been the happiest because
i had a major studio i had a major
director i was like oh my gosh we have
succeeded and yet
i had a really strong inkling about what
this project wanted to become and the
casting that was necessary to get there
and to me the cast was julia and richard
um
and i didn't have to be 100 right about
that
but but it's a sliding scale there's a
sort of palette of colors if you will
and as i was watching all these other
actresses and actors come through
some of them were just meetings because
they were too big to audition they were
just big names there were meetings they
were auditions
some were screen tests
and as i watched some of these
meetings and auditions and certainly the
screen tests i felt my it was like my
heart hurt i had my heart set
i just i trusted my gut i've always
trusted my gut on casting
and it's not that i'm right it's just a
gut
i knew what the film could be with
richard and julia
and if i couldn't have one or the other
or both
we'd do the very next best thing but
when i saw some of these screen tests
and auditions and they were so the far
side
of
dare i say the vision that i had for or
that jonathan and i had for it
there were moments when i felt i was
seeing the premature death of my film of
the film
and and i couldn't help but feel
anxious and sad and like we
we've got to find a solution here
but again the god smiled we got our
dream cast and it all worked out
i think i think part of the lesson there
is you really have to know
when and how to speak to an issue and
speak up to the right people at the
right time
and really
try and influence
the outcome
and then when the film hit theaters
how surprised or not surprised were you
with the crowd's reception
well it's always a surprise
you know people always say did you know
it was a hit
the answer is no of course not we were
actually our reputation when we were
shooting was oh that little film in
trouble
uh we were again a very small batch by
studio standards we were turning it from
a comedy from a drama to a comedy
we were it was known that gary marshall
god bless him was going to be doing a
lot of improv so
it wasn't like there was oh my gosh that
film is going to be amazing no we were
like almost more like an experiment than
a film in many people's eyes
[Music]
we did a number i forget the number we
did a few test screenings in outlying
areas of la
and held focus groups afterward
and
with each successive screen test
the first one or two were like okay okay
that's good but i'm nervous
um but as we got audience reaction in
what was working and what they loved
about it and we kept throwing more humor
into it
um
the the reactions were you know you're
standing in the back of the theater a
darken theater and you've got a full
theater
and you're you're you're just
on pins and needles waiting to see are
they going to laugh in the right places
are they going to laugh in the wrong
places are they going to understand
what's going on are they what's the word
of mouth as they exit the theater
and you're watching their body language
literally are they
sitting up you know
and
the latter test certainly by the last
test screen but i'd say the last couple
of test screenings
the audience was you couldn't have asked
for a better reaction
at that point i wouldn't say oh my gosh
we have a hit no we were hopeful we were
going to live
because the patients are going to live
when it came out and did the business
that it did which was back then in 1990
march of 1990 we came out and it did
like 11 million and changed the first
weekend
that was a wow
the fact that it went up a little bit
like 12 million the second week that
told us
oh gosh
we have the best thing in the world
going for us word of mouth
people love it and they're talking about
it
um
and i don't remember precisely but that
film lived actively in theaters i was
it's at least half a year
i think it was actually slightly longer
which of course would never happen today
even back then it was an anomaly to have
a
an active theater presence for that
duration but um
i think even more surprising than that
looking back is it's over 30 years later
31 years later
and it's finding new generations of
audience around the globe
it is a film that you
it's like a machine that just keeps
churning out joy
right and
so to be associated with something like
that is really uh quite phenomenal it's
a blessing and
um
who could have guessed it that
were all of the
reviews positive was there any criticism
of the film
of the subject matter
i was
i don't recall that there was any
negative um there might have been
but i can't i can't recall that what i
do remember
was on the eve of releasing that film
the thing that had
i don't think i was alone in this
there was a certain nervousness
about putting a film out into the world
where the role you know this lead
character is a working girl and she's
young
when i met julia she was 18
when we shot the film she
was 21 or so
and she was a very youthful energy right
so she was this here's this young
beautiful girl
who's a
working girl
and as much as we tried to paint the
right version of that picture carefully
i was really concerned because it was a
time of great feminism
the glorious steinems of the world were
you know
on the front pages
and i thought we were going to get
pilloried i thought there was a good
chance that there would be a lot of
pushback that people would be upset with
us
how dare you
uh and to my great
surprise
that never
it never came to be
those very people that i was most
nervous about embraced it
um so i was actually even more than the
critics i was concerned about some big
public figures who
were leading the feminist movement at
the time and
we might have stepped on
you know we might have hit the wrong
chord here
uh but again that
the thing that really un was underlying
this story i mean it's pygmalion it's
cinderella it's a
it's eternal right it's a dreamscape
and it's a beautiful love story and
so much so that it that that i guess it
over rides
whatever
sort of socio-political instincts of the
moment might be
present
but yeah no the embrace was
i i i might have selective memory
but the embrace seemed fairly complete
if it had been released now let's
suppose have been made in
2020 2019
pre-pandemic
do you think it would have received the
same
acclaim would there have been would
there have been people that had issue
with certain things that i think i think
not
yeah okay um it's very hard to say what
might have been
uh in some ways i think the original
story might have been better received in
uh the 2020s than
than the version we made
but i don't know i don't know i mean i
think there's something as i said i
think there's something
predictably eternal about
our love of story and the way we react
to story in certain archetypes
um and certainly romance in general
so i i don't know but i think i think
that we live in a time
when people are certainly more critical
and that film might not have fared the
same
is hollywood a game gary
in a sense yes
i suppose but i think life in a way is a
game like it's
in in the best sense
um but you sort of have to understand
the rules of it
um
people talk about breaking into
hollywood
which i always find fascinating
um
because life is not
an event it's a process
right and
i think
when people think about you know people
people are very given to stories in
their craft and
their dream of what it is they want to
accomplish
we know at show business but very few
people really think about the business
side of the equation
and
i find a lot of creatives in particular
are
not intentionally random but they are
they end up being random in their
approach focusing on craft not thinking
about how they're going to navigate
as if
our industry is somehow different from
all other industries
uh which it's not
i mean it it is in a sense but it's
not in the sense of being relationship
based
and i i you know what what i would
encourage people is i
i try and train people to be hyper
focused hyper intentional
radically transparent and
not
think about needing a representative so
much as being themselves a presence
developing rapport creating
relationships in this business
and understanding that the first thing
they have to know is who are you
who are you in the world what do you
care about what
what's your creative dna what's your
signature what
what are the kinds of stories you want
to be participating in or writing or
directing or producing whatever it might
be
and then thinking about
if that's true
who is it that i really need to know
if hypothetically if i could have a
hundred people
over time
be my champions and mentors who would
they be
and that's going to be different from me
to the person sitting next to me
and then making that reality come to
come to be
right i think a lot of a lot of people
are taught unfortunate habits
so
[Music]
they learn they mimic habits of of their
peers which may or may not be optimal
writers may for example send upline
query letters that are deeply impersonal
and fly into strangers in boxes asking
them to either produce it or represent
them or whatever it might be a big ask
as opposed to humanizing the process
over and again time and time again i get
the sense that people people have a
story that hollywood is not welcoming
that it's
that they have they don't understand
their value and they don't know that the
welcome mat is out
which couldn't be further from the truth
if you approach people the way you would
in any other environment
so what i
wish for people is
that they get more comfortable being
vulnerable and telling people what's
unique about them why
who are they what's what's what's some
any one really delicious unexpected
uh nugget from their life experience
that makes them memorable
tell people share with people what was
why was this particular of all the
possible stories in the universe why
this one
what's the connective tissue why was
that so important to you that you put
all your soul equity into creating this
and a third leg of this school very
important is
don't just send it out randomly
if i want to send you this project
why you why have i chosen you
not because your name was in a directory
i researched you there was some one film
that you made perhaps that was
like i got sucker punched in the third
eye it's so spot on or maybe it's your
entire body of work
there's something
that called me to think you might be a
right size fit a good match
for me and for this particular story
say those things pick up the phone
don't rely on social media don't rely on
blind query letters make it personal
this is a personal business
reach out to someone and do not be a
snob you're not going to probably reach
the name on the door
nor do you necessarily need to
i've always learned i built my entire
career based on one simple realization
early on
all i need to do is befriend the
assistant
the assistant or of any you know when
assistants move on they go to
the next little notch up which is still
entry level it's a creative executive
it's a director production it's a you
know
head of development whatever their
titles
all of those people beginning with the
person who answers the phone which is
usually an assistant
these
are your target these are the people who
have enormous value
who are so aligned with you
you have so much in common with them
they are highly vetted
they are
usually like they beat out 50 people or
more to get that particular perch
they're ambitious they're sitting on the
inside learning the business and on a
producer's desk or an agent's desk or
whatever it might be casting studio
and they are
going to last in that position for 18 24
some number of months
and they will matriculate because
they're really good
and they've had to work really hard and
and you know that's their sharpening
stone
these people need relationships with you
as much as you need one with them
and most people don't understand that
it's like the currency of most of us is
who's
what relationships do i enjoy with
talent in front of the camera behind the
camera it doesn't matter
do i know other good producers writers
cinematographers actors
whatever it might be casting directors
we're all in the business of
relationship
and so
it's a beautiful game of human failures
and everyone is instead of being narrow
focused and saying i'm just going to
i'm not going to share who i am as an
artist as a creator as a writer
i'm going to put out a blind query
letter with a log line etc
and i'll send it to a stranger who does
not yet know me
and i'm going to hope and pray
to get a good response
and
the common refrain is
not a positive response
i send out hundreds i get two responses
there usually passes
very typical
as opposed to saying i'm going to dare
to be uncomfortable and awkward for a
moment
i'm going to take a minor risk it's not
threatening my life but i'm going to
take a minor risk of being uncomfortable
and i'll call someone who does not know
me
and i'm going to introduce myself and
i'm not going to ask a big favor
the first couple of calls i'm only going
to ask advice
it's gonna that's what i learned early
on is like make everyone your mentor
ask advice keep the call to three four
minutes
do it again a week later
do it again a week later
make a friend
and they're
as desirous of that as you are
you just have to catch them when they're
not overwhelmed
um
so i think i think you know it's a funny
word is hollywood a game and i think
yeah if you want to win at this if you
really want to have a
viable sustainable career as a creative
what's interesting is the artist
you all you know everyone has more than
one story one hopes
um and the story may be brilliant but
what makes it really interesting is the
point of view of the creator
and why they did it and what's their
life experience we
we react to one another we are attracted
to that
and even if someone falls in love with
one of your scripts
they're never going to go forward with
it and lessen until they meet you
the creator
so i think i think in a sense you know
it's it's really
having that sort of divine inspiration
that just comes down and gives you the
permission like oh my gosh i don't need
permission i can just reach out
and talk to whoever i want no one is
unreachable
that was my earliest lesson
no one is unreachable
if you're humble if you're vulnerable if
you're if if you make it pleasant you're
you know and you can say to someone
oh my gosh i'm terrified i'm so nervous
to be calling you
even to an assistant
because it's true as long as it's true
but the more you
[Music]
let yourself be known
and the more other focused you become
[Music]
the more generous you are the more you
share and ask questions that are like
of human you know truly interesting to
humans
it's it works magic
you win over an assistant and i know i'm
rambling on but if you went over an
assistant
you went over everybody in that office
because they have the full trust of
everyone in that office they've been
hired
relied on they're a critical part of the
of that mission
um if you want to win over an aw you
know a group of people get to know their
assistant
so it is a game in some sense
and to get in the game
you find that one assistant
person that's there before everyone else
maybe making coffee
getting it ready answering the phones
how do you do it in a way that's genuine
well the question is the answer
by being genuine
and saying you know i when i was new
i would just turn to people and say
i'm new
i'm the turnip that just fall off the
truck
but i'm really committed to making it in
this business but i know how much i
don't know i have a couple of questions
if you could spend three minutes
answering my questions it would mean the
world to me
people can't resist the truth
if it's real if it's genuine
um when i would call assistants
of course you don't know who they are
it's just a person answering the phone
and i would just introduce myself and
say look this is and it's what i was
talking about earlier
i'm an aspiring screenwriter or fill in
the blank
i am
absolutely mesmerized by the work your
company consistently puts out into the
world
that's why i'm reaching out
and yes i have a project that's very
much that shares a lot of kinship with
the kinds of projects stories that you
tell
but i'm not sending it to you i'm not
asking you to read my script
i just want to establish
a relationship with you
and i get their name so that i can when
i'm off the call research them and find
out all sorts of delicious stuff about
them
online
and i will have a question or two and
it's usually
something i know they can answer it
might be you know how do you operate as
a company are you you know i'm not going
to send you my script but are do you
accept outside material it could be
were you there at the time they made
this last film that came out in march
that was just so phenomenal
how did you get to be there how did how
did you get to work for this
extraordinary company
and where do you want to go
i mean i know you don't want you know
you're you're paying dues you're
sitting in the crosshairs of this
amazing opportunity
but where do you see yourself in a few
years
um
you know where'd you go to school
did you go to film school
i'll ask any question that comes up in
the moment for me
um but there will be questions to which
i really do want the answer it'll be
it'll help inform me about this person
and i always build in and say look you
know i've used up my four minutes you've
been amazingly kind
to take my call i just want you to know
i really appreciate it and i have
another question i'm thinking about a
couple of things but i'd like you know
what
you're busy
i'm you know i'm going to let you go
but i'm going to call you a week from
today
if you have three or five minutes
available that would be absolutely
extraordinary
but thank you
i researched the heck out of them i
called them back the next week exactly
when i said i would
and if they're available great and if
they're not
i call back again
my idea is that people are very
welcoming
if that's your expectation that's
probably going to be the reality
if you welcome that it can be a very
welcoming experience
i don't mind people sending me query
letters but i'll tell you there's
universe galaxy of difference between if
someone sends me a query letter and i've
never spoken i have no idea who they are
and they're sending me a storyline
with the goal of me reading and possibly
producing it or whatever their intention
is
versus
someone who's reached out to either me
or someone on my team
making themselves known as a human
developing some rapport
taking the time
investing a multiple of calls over the
course of a month let's say
and now they're really familiar with
someone on my team
and that person and this happens all the
time
whether it was as a manager or as a
producer someone would come to me and
say you know i've met so and so and um
they're really nice
i think they're really smart and i've
just read some of their work because you
do that after three or four calls now
when the the welcome mat is out
would you take a look at it
my answer is always yes
that's that's my team member
you know and and and that's kind of the
reality now it might not be direct to me
it might be to my head of development or
it might be some but that's how you
penetrate that's how you get welcomed in
a query letter after you've spoken with
a human that's addressed to the human
you spoke to is a totally different
experience
than just a strange peach unexpected
email coming into my inbox or someone
else you know why why is it coming into
my inbox
and i that's not to be that's not hubris
it's just pragmatism
there are so many ways
to play the long game
build rapport
with the faith that the long game is
actually the faster track
we often hear it's impossible to get a
screenplay read and especially now so
many new writers want to get in to
netflix
want to get a meeting with someone
is it impossible
no it's not impossible
um but i think you have to calibrate you
have to be
realistic um i mean
people talk about netflix a lot
certainly it's the big line in the
jungle
and
we see a lot of good projects being
produced are required so that's great
netflix is actually one of the companies
being as big as they are it's
understandable they're a company who
basically advertises they have a policy
that we if we don't have an existing
relationship with you don't knock on our
door
so it would seem
logical
that people would have this feeling like
oh i can't get read
but there's
but it's but it's really not what it
seems
what they're really saying is
invest a little time
make yourself known to us how do you do
that
um well in the case of the first of all
there's there's there's a couple dozen
very vibrant streamers
not just netflix they're not the world
of streaming they're one of the biggest
of
and there's a lot of places that you can
go who don't have
uh you know the policy if we don't
accept unsolicited material or you can't
come pitch us whatever it might be
but if you really want to get in the
door
it reminds me of you know back in the
day when
carlos antenna wanted to play at
fillmore west up in san francisco and
bill graham the empresario was like i
don't know who this kid is and he you
know people you knock and you knock and
you knock it's like jeffrey kastenberg
always used to say if if you can't get
in the front door go through the back
door if you get in the back door climb
through a window if you can't go in
through the basement there's a way in
and that's true
well carlos santana climbed up a
drainpipe on the exterior of the
building to the third floor and fell
through the window into bill graham's
office
that's how they met
well i don't recommend that necessarily
but it worked it started his career
by the same token if you want to get
into netflix
how hard is it to research who are all
the people who've either produced for
them an original or had a film acquired
by them
and cozy up to them
this is a team sport this is it takes a
village
to get any project made serious feature
limited series docu-series whatever
so you're going to want to be knowing
these people regardless well why don't
you just find the ones who are doing the
kinds of projects
genre budget that are similar to yours
who happen to have that relationship
and go that route
there's a lot of ways in
um
but there's the other and and the other
way
is
there are a lot of people who work at
netflix
befriend them
it's not all this is not a like a pass
fail report card or menu of options
it's a human reality
if you really are determined to get into
netflix there are people at all levels
from from assistant all the way up
where you can identify them and you can
find them on linkedin they're they're
named
and you can reach out to them and you
can do what we were just talking about a
moment ago which is introduce yourself
but not to say i want a pitch meeting or
i want you to read my script i just want
to get to know you
because what happens is if you actually
invest a couple of short calls doing
that over a period of weeks
that prohibition against we don't deal
with strangers or we don't read
unsolicited material vanishes it
evaporates because now you're not
unknown
that's a human metric
and you can overcome that
um
now i'll share a quick story about
many many years ago
i always when i have a project i always
put together what i call a top 100 list
who are the people that ideally in every
category that i want to that i would
want to approach to talk about this
project
from editors and writers and
cinematographers and casting directors
to producers to buyers studios streamers
you name it
and i will just go through that list and
prioritize them and i'll reach out to
them and usually again it may not be the
name on the door or maybe it is
um
but the idea
um
the story that i want to share is that
years ago i i made a list
and
um
it wasn't arrogance it was just i'm
it was a dream
so i added a name to my list that was
the most
preeminent name in hollywood at the time
and probably still is steven spielberg
so here i am a little guppy and i put
the name of steven spielberg on my list
and i think you know
you know normally you would think oh
sober up child it's not gonna happen
but as it turns out i had gotten to know
uh this wonderful guy young guy named
mitch who was an entry-level guy
i met him when he was an assistant he
got promoted to creative executive and
he was now a creative executive at amlin
his ultimate boss was stephen
and um so i spent some months just
nurturing that relationship
and one day
someone sent me a script and it was
absolutely
gorgeous it was beautifully crafted a
story young characters kind of a very
special care very emotional
young
young leads
but it was just
tremendously well done
so i called up this fellow whose name
was mitch and i said mitch
i read this script we'd been
co-conspirators we're both starting out
in the business we were friends now new
friendship
and we were excited
so he read it
and he called me back he read it on the
weekend the usual monday morning call
back and he he called me back he said
he praised it he said this is absolutely
gorgeous it was very emotional it took
me back to when i was that age i had a
not dissimilar experience
fabulous thank you it was really really
interesting
it's going to be a pass
and i said okay mitch
um
i one favor
why
why is this a pass you just
you were just singing at spratuses and
it's because it's too small for steven
i said okay that's fair
i understand that
but let me ask you a question if
you put this script in steven's
briefcase for his weekend read and he
were to come back monday and say to you
this is a pass
would you have any and specifically
whether it's because it's too small or
otherwise would you have any cause for
embarrassment
would it in any way jeopardize your
standing in the company
they said no it's a brilliant script
i said great then i am on
we're on a phone you can't see me but
i'm on one knee and i am begging you
put it in steven's briefcase
and he did
steven read it
and he wanted to buy it
now
no one was more stunned than i was
but i think this is a business that
turns on belief it's a business that
turns on passion it's a business that
you just got to go with your instincts
and get your head out of the game
sometimes because this is the fear
factor right this is the
don't take risk factor
speak the truth
and make friends of people
if i can get stephen spielberg to want
to buy a script
i mean he didn't gary goldstein's name i
might as well have been the clerk at the
local convenience store
right
if an agent by the way
had sent that very same script on my
behalf
it would have been absolutely a pass it
would never have gotten to stephen
because
it wasn't about report wasn't about an
exploration it was like okay it's a pass
i get it
um
magic happens when you make yourself
available when you make yourself known
when you care enough
to ask the right questions to speak your
truth
the fact that i as a young guppy in the
business could get
the attention of steven spielberg and
maybe actually have a project together
was unthinkable
people would have said you're nuts
so do i think that
it's hard to get your script read i
think it's hard to get your script read
when you don't take risk
if you're relying on the wrong mindset
the wrong strategy
a blind query letter
or relying on some third party
we all of us need we deserve
to get in the game we deserve to have
relationships
to have
cohorts and
collaborators and champions and fans and
allies and
help one another mutually
at what point is too much though i think
many people in the entertainment
industry they're long on enthusiasm but
sometimes
certain times it can be too much maybe
they gotta sort of reel it back in
because you don't want to hurt your
reputation where
oh it's that person again
that happens often um and and it may be
um
a very well intended enthusiasm sure but
the enthusiasm i think you're referring
to is a very self-facing enthusiasm okay
so it's it's
it's it's maybe not intended to be
overly grand or braggadocio or any of
that but it may come across that way
uh or just too self-focused period
right so
what i
would share with people is is that idea
that
vulnerability and honesty and truth
is not a push energy
it's a pull energy it's a very
attractive energy
but don't spend the whole time talking
about yourself in fact
one of the great life lessons in not
just hollywood but in life is
fewer words listen more
the less you say
the fewer words you use to communicate
the more the other person remembers
if you talk too much this just becomes
a blur
but be other focused
care about the other person be curious i
think that curiosity
and gratitude and all you know they're
by words today but they're real
those are real energies and if i
approach you and i'm grateful for you
know thank you so much for taking this
call not over being overly solicitous
but just honest
um
and asking about you know how you know
how long have you been there and how did
you get that job it's awesome and where
do you aspire to go
i would probably be the only person not
only that day but that week month and
possibly longer
who's actually
shown a genuine curiosity or interest in
you
because everyone else is in a rush to
get past you to the boss
it's easy to make friends in this
business
actually
but
you're right you can't assault people
with enthusiasm and expect it to be an
effective strategy
it has to be very moderated
less is more
quiet is better than loud
truth is better than
grandiosity
so it's just being measured
um because it's it's it's
it's hard to you know the g-force of
people's enthusiasm can be
um unwelcome
if you were starting from zero today how
long do you think it would take you to
get into a place like netflix
to pitch ideas it's a great question i
i think it takes i think it takes a
while it's going to take a while
regardless you have to be committed you
have to be willing to invest some time
in the olden days
we networked in a different way we
showed up in person for coffee breakfast
lunch dinner office meetings non-stop
the advantage of i mean the downside to
that was it was extraordinarily time
consuming the upside of that was it was
very personal
the advantage of today is we can reach
anyone we want i can google anybody find
out how to get in touch with them where
they are where they work if i don't know
someone at that agency or that streamer
i can find out who works there
i can reach out to them very quickly
digitally i can speak to them on a phone
i can get them on a zoom i can do
whatever you know those are those
options are very available to us so we
can truncate the time
but we need more frequency of
interaction because of the lack of
personal connection if we're not sitting
across a lunch table from them it's
different
but again i
i really think that's incumbent on us to
be so conscious and present and aware of
what our mission is and how we want to
get there
i think the problem today is
we are separated by
technology
or we're connected by technology but
we're not physically in the room with
them more often than not people are
saying do i need to be in la no you
don't need to be in la if you're in la
you'd be having the same number of
meetings that you're having right now
initially for the foreseeable
so technology's our friend but it's not
as personal the hardest part back then
was finding someone and getting together
physically with them so you could have a
relationship with them
today
you can find identify someone quickly in
an instant online and you can reach out
to them instantly
by email by phone what have you
uh but you have to invest in that and
make it personal you have to come across
in a different way if you're
if the if the intention is i just want a
pitch meeting that's going to be hard
especially at a place like netflix
until you build your
those bridges those rapport-based
bridges that let you walk into that
opportunity
so i think it's really less about
how is it the same or how is it
different than are we are we
ready willing and able
to invest ourselves in
bridge building human bridge building
or
are we just looking for someone to set
us up for a meeting one is realistic one
is not
years ago
an actor friend of mine
i ran into him and he was
he wasn't in a good mood he was he was
upset with himself and i said what's
going on and
he told me he'd just been to an audition
and he didn't get the gig
and i said what was it tell me about the
role tell me the project who was in the
room blah blah blah
so he tell he fills in all the details
and it turns out
it was the casting director the casting
associate the the
producer i think the director was i'm
not 100 sure but there was at least one
producer there anyway it was a project
he really wanted these were really good
people
but he didn't get it and he left and
that was it he was in a total funk
that's that's interesting
so
why are you so hard on yourself and he
was like what are you talking about i
didn't get the gig
i said well look i i we may i'm not an
actor so what do i know but i have this
crazy idea
that the i the purpose of an audition
is primarily to get invited back
that to get the gig is secondary
like look who you just told me was in
the room
these are like people
people dream about meeting these people
and you just spent time with them
and so
i again it may be naive but i think if
you walk in and you're smiling and you
greet the assistant and you greet
everyone in the room
and of course you're going to give your
very finest performance
but you let them know you as a
personality and you make it fun
and you thank them
and you greet them on the way out
there's a million reasons why you might
be might not be correct for that role
but they'll remember you
and the job is to just get invited back
because if you're on the spectrum if no
is over here and yes is over here
these twins that were never separated at
birth right they're essential to each
other
if you're on the spectrum and and
you're invited back you're inching
toward your goal
eventually they're going to hire you
it's a given
that's my belief that's my experience
so
if if you know like people always says
how do you handle rejection i celebrate
it it's like i'm in the game
i'm doing something right
and it's
it's an opportunity and that was you
know i i did a ted talk about it no it's
just a conversation starter it's i
really believe that it's like when
someone says
like in the mitch story if someone says
no to me this is going to be a pass it's
like fabulous i totally upend their
expectation instead of like
and making them uncomfortable my
attitude is great that's fantastic
the only thing that would be better
is if you tell me why
like i want to learn
and what's happening is yes you're
learning but what you've also done is
you've bonded more deeply like that's a
human
experience that is not common
you're gracious you're curious you're
thankful
and you're open
that's the person people want to work
with
when you were actively reading
screenplays how hard was it for you to
find a great screenplay
um
it it's always a challenge
it's funny i i just had um
i just had lunch on the weekend with an
executive producer a very popular tv
series and he reminds me that we met
back in like he was quoting me from 1989
like
who remembers that far back
um
and the thing he one of the one of the
things he remembered was me saying you
know i feel lucky if one out of a
hundred
gets me really excited
and i think that's you know i don't know
if that's mathematically true but it
seems like that's the case
um and it's not because it's not always
because
the quality is not there or you know or
it's not always about the caliber of the
writing it's oftentimes because
for example me as a consumer
and as a producer
i'm probably not the right guy to
write you know or to produce a um a big
sci-fi movie or certain other kinds of
affair there are certain kinds of
interactions or stories that really
appeal to me and many that don't but i'm
always writing to see
how talented someone is like how what
what kind of storyteller are they
um but yeah i would say personally i'm
i'm not i've never been a volume
producer i've always been pretty fussy
but i would say if i find one out of a
hundred that's worth having a
conversation to see if there's a there
there
if we get along if we agree about the
vision for the project if it's something
we want to
roll up our sleeves on together
it's probably about one percent
and that was going to be my next
question do you think that
we often hear that 99 of screenplays
written are horrible
what's your experience
oh gosh
that's really hard to say 99 of
screenplay is written and that's a big
pool
um
usually by the time i you know
there's there's there's sort of a
natural
evolution
so
i'm really not taking scripts off the
internet or
i'm not posting on public forums saying
send me your scripts so i don't know
what the big the bigger ocean of
opportunity looks like
i usually get scripts sent to me through
people who
are either writers that i know their
representatives their attorney their
friend
someone in the business a producer
another producer might want to share
something with me
horrible's a horrible word
[Laughter]
um
certainly there are those that i read
where i go gosh this is way off the mark
there's i ca you know it's
it's i really want to root just like for
a movie same for a screenplay i i am
that guy who i'm rooting for the writer
i'm rooting for the story i want to love
this
if i read something that's so poorly
written that i just can't get through
the whole of it
that's as disappointing as it is you
know
like okay so it's not for me that's fine
but it's disappointing i want that to be
better i want that person to be better
to be a better at their craft
what do you think 99 of screenplays get
wrong
wow great question
i don't know if there's a
sort of that ubiquitous one thing that
they all get wrong
i just think that one one of the things
writers
i would like to see more writers have
sort of a more systematic
reality check system inner circle system
so that
at a given point in time if they feel
it's ready for prime time they really
have a trusted group of not friends and
family but seasoned people people in the
business
who know their stuff and how to read a
script
and get the feedback
um
i always do that to this day i still
i know that we get so close our
our face is pressed up against the glass
we've been working on something for
seven or twelve or whatever number of
rewrites and
we lose perspective
and if i were to give it to you and four
other people and you all come back with
one similar comment i know that i have a
real issue that i've overlooked
if all five of you come back with
criticisms but they're all different
that's a win
it's like okay now i can pick and choose
which ones make sense which ones do in
my gut i really feel enhance the story
i think so i think one of the things is
not not falling too in love or feeling
too precious about the material that you
create
but really being open and willing to
find the you know and bold enough and
brave enough to find the very best
version of the story and that requires
i i hear a lot of writers talk about
well
um
i i really don't want to change it that
much you know it's no this is you know
that's be a painter be a sculptor
write a novel
this is a medium that's designed for
collaboration and i think you need to
take that as an asset as a positive
and invite it
because it's going to happen eventually
how many pages into a screenplay before
you know
it's a bad screenplay
not long
there are many and and i sort of agree
if someone doesn't grab me somehow in
the first three pages
with the quality of their craft or
something that's surprising in a good
way
um
that's that's what i'm hoping for
someone really putting a hook in my
mouth
but 10 pages in
easily 15 pages and you you sort of see
the caliber of the writing that the
the quality of the craft
um it's it's it's not likely that the
the actual quality of the writing is
going to shift on page 30 or 60.
when you sat down to read three thousand
later to be called pretty woman
where were you i was in um i owned a
home in west hollywood it was this
absolutely charming 1920s bungalow style
classic hollywood bungalow right
all sunlight beautiful yard the whole
thing and
i had a room that was just like my
reading room it was a small like sunroom
uh and yeah that's where i did most of
my reading at night on the weekend
and yeah i i like to read at home as
opposed to say at the office
so it was a friday night and you
i don't remember what day of the week it
might have been all i can tell you is i
was waiting with great anticipation
i had very high hopes because i was so
um
admiring of jonathan and what i'd
what i knew of him as a person but
certainly what i'd seen on the page
and the only question was
could he really sort of jump it up to
that level of maturity and
um
i promise you the moment he delivered it
to me i probably at that moment
wherever i was
turned off the phone if we had phones
that turned off whatever you know
metaphorically and it was like okay this
is the most important thing i have to do
this week i'm gonna go home and read
this
and so
three pages in you're loving it five
pages in
were you waiting for the other shoe to
drop
where you had notes and you thought this
isn't or you
no the thing about no i don't go into it
with that sort of lens
i'm not looking for what's wrong
it's just not my way
when someone grabs me from the beginning
which he did
when
it's not heavy-handed it's just right
when that happens and i'm engrossed and
i'm invited into this and i'm he's got
me right
until he stops getting me
i'm not operating from here
right
and
that was from cover to cover that was my
experience i never really intellectually
assessed the script
that's why i was so excited about it
because if i didn't i figure a lot of
other people won't that they'll have an
experience somewhat similar to mine
where they're so engrossed in the
characters that the way it plays out in
the dialogue and and all those other
supporting roles and and the friendships
and
the tensions and whatnot that
they're going to swim through the script
the same way i did
and that's what i pray for it's like
that's
that's the win
any tips you can give screenwriters that
would immediately improve
their screenplays especially in those
first few pages
i don't think there's any sage guidance
that i have other than to recognize what
you just said which is the opening of
your script is so important
you really want to set the table
right up front
invite people let let people know what
you're you're inviting them into
um i've seen scripts that start out with
like
a page and a half or two pages of single
narrative description
not a good way to start a screenplay
to make us do that much work to get to
our characters or the action
so
i would say you know really take
absolute advantage
and
you know we're in the entertainment
business entertain me starting from
the first moment
but other than that i don't think i mean
every story is so uniquely different
not just because of the conventions of
the various genres but just
the storytellers are different and the
um
i can't i can't think
of it's really yeah never mind i'm
rambling
it's it's just the recognition that you
that you bring up in your by way of your
question
what's the dna of a writer
people are so fascinating
i i i don't know that i've ever met
someone who is not
possessed of the most surprising story
in life experience
and the only people who don't know it is
the person living that story
they take them you know people take
themselves for granted they tell a
lesser version they have these sort of
they they they don't see themselves the
way i see them or the way you might see
them
um
i think the dna of a writer is so deeply
anchored
both in this life experience ancestrally
in every sense
um
there's a wonderful quote
by ben kingsley
and i can't remember it precisely but
it's something like
our work evolves
and over time it becomes less careful
less anal
less conscious
and more a reflection of the truth of
our soul
and i think that's really the journey of
an artist
it's there but it needs to be freed it's
like carving the day of it or letting
off wine mature and it's like as we grow
into what we do and we relax into it and
we have the confidence that we don't
have to we're not thinking from the neck
up so much
we're finding the truth zone right
um
[Music]
i think we spend much of our life
mastering something becoming really good
at the craft whatever that is whether
it's a creative pursuit or not
but then in time you just cross this
sort of invisible threshold
where it just you start taking deeper
cuts
you trust yourself
that's when it gets really interesting
what's the difference between writing as
a hobby and writing as a career the
difference
between a hobby and a career as a writer
it's a choice
um
and sometimes that choice is conscious
and sometimes it's not
there may be someone who you know who
who is a hobbyist
who's as serious and and devoted and and
possessed by the act of writing
as anyone else
they may lack the commitment to do what
it takes to make a career out of it
and there are a lot of people who think
it's a career but they haven't you know
like what's the measure of a career
well the measure of a career would be
superficially are you earning a living
doing it
but would also be are you really getting
the appreciation acknowledgement are you
forging the relationships with the
people who really constitute that
community in a meaningful way
or are you an outlier
and not an outlier but are you are you
an outsider
who's really not knocking on those doors
um
i think there are so many brilliant
stories that get lost to us that are
important
because people don't knock on the door
because they're they're more
content
in the safety of it being a hobby they
may not refer to it as the word hobby
but not really
and i think there are a lot of artists
who need champions
they need people they need a sherpa they
need a guide
you know one of my early heroes was max
perkins and max was
a man of letters he was a brilliant
writer himself but he was also
most of his adulthood and the single
best editor in my view of the in
the 20th century in america
and he was the father figure who
discovered
uh and nurtured and launched careers
for faulkner and hemingway and ring
lardner and thomas wolf and just the
list goes on
um
and
a lot of these creatives
either would have there are a lot of
inside won't get into the particular
stories but they're they're faulkner
might easily have never come to
hollywood he might never have had
certain of his books published had it
not been for max
and the same probably is true in varying
degrees with certain of his other
illustrious
um so clients
think it's sort of a
you know
it's it's hard to adjudicate
at what point
people have the constitution to really
take it into their own hands and say
consciously i'm going to be disciplined
i'm going to find my way in
or i'm just going to be a soloist and
enjoy the act of writing
and
there's a lot of gray in between those
two
um i think the first thing is just to
recognize the
phenomenal joy if that's your
if that's true for you right like for me
i'm a natural writer i'm not an author
and i'm not a screenwriter i'm a writer
they're different
i take enormous joy in writing it's one
of my happiest moments of the day
but i don't see that i'm a professional
writer
i think my my
my marketplace skills are better
i'm better as a producer i'm better as a
fire starter and a facilitator and an
organ orchestrator
um than being and i'm a very good editor
but i'm i don't think i'm a screenwriter
so it's kind of knowing yourself and how
far you want to push it
and do you have the gumption
to do so
if we were going to break down the day
of two screenwriters so one who is quote
waiting to be discovered versus one who
as you say leverages their entertainment
career
what would those two days look like
gosh very different um now they may have
equal levels of discipline or lack of
discipline when it comes to how and when
and where they write
i mean some writers it's like they're
early morning writers or their nighttime
writers or whatever is their sort of
biorhythm creatively right
and do they do that consistently and do
they block out a certain number of hours
and do they hang the same go on fishing
sign on the door so the family knows
leave me alone right
so those are all one sort of one
category of
of um discipline and decision that a
creative makes one is self-response
makes a decision to be self-responsible
like it would be great to have an age
but it's not essential i'm still going
to make it so i'm going to be
intentional and i'm going to allocate a
certain amount of my brain and my
my heart and my consciousness and my
time
to having a plan i'm going to build my
own plan
i'm going to say i'm going to dedicate
anywhere from 30 minutes a day to an
hour a day to two hours a day on my
career versus
the hours that i spend writing which is
about my craft
i'm going to have a vision a plan long
term short term in the next month or you
know every month i want to make these
kinds of measurable steps forward i
wanted this to happen in six months this
to happen in 12 months
and you may or may not hit those marks
but the intention the entrepreneurial
sort of energy
of yeah there's this other rail this
other track
that i'm gonna pay attention to and and
and
respect as much as i respect the greater
amount of time that i spend with the
actual writing
and it's got to be consistent it's like
an athlete when you're training you know
it's you've got to be
um
you've got you've got to be a bit
rigorous
and say
you know what what do i need if i'm
going to succeed
you know if if my manuscript or my
screenplay is not going to
chew off its own head in their drawer
while it gathers dust what do i need
i need a team i need to know people i
need people to
collaborate with and i need people to
you know who are
but before i need them
i want to have the relationship with the
people that eventually i'm going to need
when i have a new project ready
who are those people
uh and then make it a point to
build out your i mean there's nothing
more important than just i i i don't
really love the word networking but
that's what it is
it's saying i need i need my village i
need my tribe i need my team
whatever that looks like
and i'm not talking just about a
representative i mean a real community
of people that are my
my creative collab
so twitter
going on twitter being a part of writer
organizations whether they're on social
media or separate from social media
absolutely
where do i get immerse myself in that
conversation so that i can get feedback
so that i can find resources i can share
resources and opportunities and if i
want to introduce someone to someone
else
it'll be a generosity that's well
received and reciprocated
yeah put yourself in that flow when
you're not
in your writing space
i think it's
and and not just and not just with other
writers
i think it's important
that you color outside the lines and
that you be a little bit imaginative and
daring not just with your writing but in
your choice of
uh you know
we've talked about this before most
writers uh
think in terms of agents or producers
either representation or who's going to
get my help get my project produced and
that's all wonderful
but there are all these other people out
there that people aren't knocking on
their door and they're available and
they'd love to talk to you and share
their wisdom
so why aren't we reaching out to
the line producer the casting director
the cinematographer etc etc are editors
and other writers that you can glean
inordinate wisdom from
and have real fun with
so i think that you know it doesn't
always have to be specific you know like
a specific result or goal that you want
to achieve it's just saying
my greatest currency
is really being a part of this community
that is the filament
and tv enterprise right i i need to
walk the streets of my community and
know my neighbors
and be able to talk to them and
be welcoming of them
and what if you're shy and maybe they're
not welcoming of
you i don't believe for a moment that
they're not welcoming
i do believe that a lot of people are
shy
and
but that's you know being shy is not an
excuse not to succeed
it's just not
um
it's hard but i've had i can't tell you
the number of people
that i've coached
over time
who come back and go oh my god i had no
idea
this is like you know the red sea
parting i didn't know it was so easy and
so much fun to meet people
i thought it was scary
i thought there was a monster in the
closet
i thought these were fire-breathing
weapon-wielding terrible terrible people
who didn't want to know me
and and it's like oh my god i just
forced myself and it was very
uncomfortable it was extremely awkward i
didn't like it but i forced myself to do
for one week what you suggested
and i make two calls a day for a week
and by that friday
it was like
oh my gosh
there was one person who was too busy
there was one person who had some
attitude
but eight people welcomed me
and i'm gonna be speaking with most all
of them again in another week just the
way you taught
and it's it's it's i'm not taking credit
for it it's just like it's it was just
like a push go jump in the water you're
not gonna drown
flop your arms you're gonna swim
may not look beautiful the first time
but it it doesn't take long before it's
like oh you let your shoulders down and
say you know what i can let go i can lay
down the stories that don't serve me
and a lot of people have that story that
oh i'm sure
is there two sides of the coin was i'm
too shy i'm introverted i'm not
comfortable
it's scary
i don't want to do it
and the other side is they don't want me
to do it they're not friendly they're
not welcoming
i have or i have no value and nothing to
contribute to the conversation like i'm
subhuman
and those stories are just stories
they're not real
but we only learn by doing
that may be an exaggeration but i really
believe that doing is the way we learn
fastest and if you pick up the phone and
force you to do something that's really
not native to you that's really actually
quite
audacious
and you do it a few times it's suddenly
it's like public speaking
everyone says publix more people fear
public speaking than death
were you afraid of your ted talk
um
i i was always horrified of public
speaking i actually enjoy it now
the things that you worry about
no one else is worried about
it's crazy because we think we are the
universe but no
people are rooting for you
we see that all the time in performances
whether it's public speaking or you know
singing or
whatever it might be athletes you name
it
we want people to win
if you just lay those stories down long
enough to take some action
you grow a new muscle very quickly
it's not terrifying it's actually
appreciated and it's the fastest path to
from a to b
gary you're a former attorney turned
hollywood producer criminal defense
attorney correct correct okay
i'm sure you've seen some good sides of
people and maybe some not so good signs
from what you've seen how true is it
that screenplays are stolen that ideas
are stolen
or ideas really can't be stolen
well i i wouldn't go so far to say this
cannot be stolen but in my experience
it's extraordinarily rare
i see a lot of writers very concerned
about it and my my advice to them is
by all means protect your work your ip
needs to be protected you've worked hard
so at a minimum you want to put a
copyright notice on it but you also want
to register it for copyright which are
different right
and for extra
an extra layer of frosting on the cake
you might want to register it with the
writer's guild of america
after that i wouldn't worry about it
i've i personally never
the kinds of things that i'm concerned
about are not theft of intellectual
property uh so much as unfair dealings
right it's a totally different beast
um
[Music]
but but actual theft of whether it's an
idea or a
an existing screen player teleplay
um i've never personally actually had
that experience i've been in the
business a lot of years
i know it happens
only because i read about it once a
decade in the in in a trade paper that
so-and-so claims x happened
but i wouldn't be concerned about it my
attitude was always when i was managing
a young writer
i want the world to read this so i'm
willing i'll make a million copies i'll
hire a helicopter and drop it out over
the city of la and let everybody read
this beautiful script
because i don't believe they're going to
steal it
so i think there's a difference between
protecting your work and worrying about
it
and um
you know on on
the only thing i would add on the flip
side of that is
don't be too casual about where you
invest your time
and thus your where you
uh how you disseminate your script
so while i was joking about the
helicopter i'm joking it's you know
you really want to choose wisely how you
use your time who you invest your time
in meeting
um
and if you do that well
then the other becomes sort of a
non-item
you know if you're
if you're careful about who you are
building as your
you know your professional
infrastructure
then i wouldn't give a second thought to
it um i think it's it's very hard to
steal and get away with stealing
intellectual property it's a very
close-knit business
and if it were to happen there are
protections um but you can't stop it so
why worry about something you can't
stop
well from reading the comments of some
of our videos you know people have taken
a lot of
detail and and just time to recount
their stories or a story of a friend of
theirs where a lot of it sounds very
similar where they go into pitch
somewhere and then a very similar idea
comes out usually with names changed but
sometimes people said that stuff hadn't
really been totally changed so i i tend
to think
most of those stories were true but i
have no way to personally
verify that
i'm sure that is actually more common
than the theft of existing scripts
i
i also think people
need to realize that ideas
i don't know that ideas were ever all
that tremendously valuable but in
today's world less so
and i would suggest
i i would advise people not to be so
excited about their idea that they're
busy pitching as an idea all the time to
everyone they encounter
it's actually
a bad practice if you have an idea
that's that's so exciting to you then
put on the brakes and write it
and then you can protect it
but ideas that you know if you're
constantly saying oh i have this
wonderful idea let me tell you about my
idea
um
don't be surprised if somehow some
version of that seeps into someone's
consciousness intentionally with
with malice or not
and finds
a life
somewhere else
you've invited that
you know i think you have your inner
circle that you know and you trust and
you can bounce ideas with them that's
fine that's different but i'm talking
about people who are
i got an email from
[Music]
someone
two days ago
who had been at a meeting with these two
gals in malibu this young guy was at a
meeting with these two gals and he
pitched them this idea he's written he's
never written a screenplay but he's
written a couple of books apparently i
don't know the details
and they said oh well maybe gary
and i get an email saying i have this
wonderful idea you know
and i wrote him back and i said i really
am not sure what you're asking me
uh
from what you're saying it sounds like
there is no script
and he wrote back he said no it's but i
thought maybe if i wrote a treatment you
read i was like oh my gosh
um you know
i i really would would encourage you
you're a natural writer apparently
you've published books
write the screenplay
because this idea of disseminating ideas
and and and treatments
no one can grab hold of that there's no
real concrete outcome
of great value that you might anticipate
coming from that
so why do it
so
don't worry about pitching ideas if you
really feel
so connected to something actually spend
time with the screenplay
get it registered get it copyrighted and
then go from there
don't ask for permission and
tiptoe around don't wait for the
universe to bless you unless there's a
specific outcome
where it makes sense and that happens
all the time i might want to pitch an
idea
uh in the confines of uh you know a
close relationship that i might have
with let's say another producer or with
a writer so here's the i want to develop
you know here's an idea
um
does this excite you is this something
you'd be interested in working on with
me that's one context
and it makes perfect sense because it
has to be birthed we all birth stories
out of thin air there's nothing and then
there's a story
and then there's a screenplay so along
that trajectory there are times when we
want to find people that we want to draw
into the process
but to pitch it just to let people know
that we're excited about something and
we're working on something
um
you know again if it's if it's someone
you know and trusts fine but
i wouldn't make a habit of pitching
ideas
and i won't even use the word pitch
because that presumes something it's
a you know term of art but
i wouldn't necessarily be sharing
hither and yan an idea that you really
do are serious you have serious
intention that you're gonna actually
craft that into a project and do a
screenplay or tell a play
i would i would be a little bit i'd i at
least at a minimum you should create a
treatment and copyright it and you know
if you want to batten down the hatches
and be pitching the idea that's okay but
really document it
protect it
and now you have a basis for
a claim should that rare occurrence
happen which is that someone actually
steals your idea
gary you mentioned you were more worried
about unfair dealings
what does that mean well not everybody's
well behaved
hollywood's no exception um
i you know so there are we all say we
have war stories right and and certainly
there have been
i'll give you an example
um
i will try not to dance around it so
it's there are many versions of it
here's one version one version is
an agent calls me and says i have a hip
pocket client
would you meet with her absolutely i'm
delighted to meet with her
i asked for a little bio biographical
material maybe anything she's written
whether it's a screenplay or not just
so i i welcome her she comes for a
meeting
and she's absolutely fascinating really
funny and bright it's hysterical her
family is remarkable and she um
i won't get into because maybe it's
identifiable but anyway there's
something very unique going on it's but
the family is eccentric and brilliant
and
um
so she she's just
i always ask a lot of questions so she's
filling me in on this whole family
history and her personal journey after
college and this and that the other
thing and i said this is all great okay
great so an hour into it i said would
you mind
terribly if i pitch you a story
and she's like
okay
and all i did was i took everything she
just told me
which she would never have conceived of
as a story worthy of the big screen
and i pitched her a comedy because it
was
like an intelligent comedy like
brilliant
and i pitched it back to her as a
feature idea
and you could see her eyes getting
saucer wide very excited like oh my god
that's my family's story that's me
and she said i love it i said okay so
here's the thing you said you're going
back home for a visit
so
i would love to ask not as a homework
assignment but just you know if you
would
gather up the local newspaper publisher
gather up a bunch of the editorials
copies of the paper bring back your
yearbooks from school bring back these
abcdefg
and let's dig into this this could be a
lot of fun
and she was all excited like this is
amazing yes i want to do this this is
great i said thank you for coming by
she i said do uh call me you know just
be in touch when you're back she said
i'll be gone three weeks
so four weeks go by five weeks go by
and i think you know i'm going to call
her agent
and i called her agent i said um
you know so and so was so lovely and we
i i know we talked about it and it was
such a great meeting and she was going
to be gone three weeks and she said
she'd be in touch when she got back and
i haven't heard from i just want to make
sure is everything okay
and the agent said well i have good news
and bad news
so the good news is that the project
that you
discussed with her
is now set up and i said let me guess
that the bad news
i'm not involved
and she said yeah
and she gave me a reason the reason
in that instance was
well i took it to a senior vice
president and she has some people with
deals and she needed to feed a project
to one of their people that are under
contract and us
no that's lovely of you to try and find
a reason to make me feel better but it
doesn't because i know the only reason
i'm not involved is because you didn't
want me involved
had you said there was a producer on it
it never would have occurred to an
executive to think otherwise
um so there look these things happen and
over the course of several decades
you're going to have a multiple of these
stories
lost opportunities
uh uh
people who be but just
exercise poor judgment
um
omit information
amid information um
act what they think may be in their
self-interest that may or may not be
true
you know i've i've
i've set up projects in studios on a
handshake with the under verbal
understanding with an agent
different from the story i just told
that they wouldn't close the you know uh
they wouldn't paper the
underlying rights to the script
on behalf of their writer client until
my producing deal was at least codified
as an email informally right
um and i've had that violated
now you think to yourself
how would a person do that
because they were going to get a
commission
on my fee
right a single project commission
well it makes no sense that they would
chop my knees off
because it's going to cut my fee in half
but they do it
um and i'm not it's like i still got a
movie made i've still made a great fee
right
uh was i happy about it no
but
you know you can't here's the thing
i trust people
and i would much rather go through life
like very very occasionally being
disappointed
rather than going through life
mistrusting people and saying you got a
sign you know everything has to be
buttoned down
i expect you're going to behave badly no
because the truth is that
i can tell you stories but
they're
they're they're they're a needle in the
haystack of my experience over the
course of my years in the business
most people behave reasonably well
and it's on us i do think it's incumbent
on us to be really clear
and state aloud
what we care about
and what we expect and
if we're uncomfortable then just do a
one-page memo i mean there is a lesson
i'm too trusting i know that
but there's a way not to have that be
your experience on a consistent basis
it's
you know if you stay in any business
long enough you're gonna have a couple
of disappointments
but they're not life-altering
one
hopes gary why do you say talent comes
second to marketing for anyone trying to
make it in hollywood
we can never underestimate talent
craft is everything
but it's not everything
meaning
fundamentally hollywood is is is is not
a meritocracy
it's not always
the best talent that rises to the top
it's not the best
projects to get financed and
and produced and
bought
um
it's it's often based on who has the
best relationships
um
so while it's really important and i
trust that most creatives who really
want to make it in the business
are steadfast they're committed they're
studying they're writing multiple
scripts they're
they're always improving it's a it's a
process it's a learning so you're always
getting better at your craft and i
and i don't underestimate the value of
that
so talent's important but talent that is
not
connected up with
some form of
effective marketing idea an action plan
some kind of a road map to make sure
that you and your body of work get
noticed
it can't live in isolation talent has to
be
have a have a platform it has to be
announced to the world and marketed and
i think that too many writers
um
tend to ignore them the the business
side the marketing side in favor of
being very uh committed to their writing
and
and hoping to get an agent
being in other words being passive in
the face of
what in any other industry would be
considered perhaps unrealistic
so i think talent is not to be
underestimated it's it's it's it's um
it's why we're all here
but the talent needs um it needs a
companion energy
so that you are
not
a best kept secret
does that have to do with uh biz dev
versus the sales mindset does that have
anything
yeah i mean
certainly i think in a way it does the
so that you know this the sales person
is is someone who's working against
quota and within a given time horizon in
there and they're looking for a specific
result which is sale they're
uh their whole approach is geared toward
uh getting getting the sale
the bus the biz dev person has a totally
different job definition a different
there's a different prism or lens that
they're looking through
they're looking it's like the difference
almost between in the old version
agency and management one was like
income driven commission driven and the
other was commission german but it was
really about developing the talent
longer term mindset
in business the biz dev people
people with that responsibility set
are really looking at how do i nurture
and develop the future
business and that's not about making
sales today that's about getting to know
their business about getting to know
their customer about getting to know
their needs their wants
and how we can develop a mutually
beneficial relationship it's being
fundamentally other focused
it's not about what i need today it's
about how can i help you now and into
the future
let's let's let's create that pathway
so that i lock in a sense of loyalty and
a deeper understanding and then we can
build together
so there's an inv it's it's investment
minded as opposed to sales minded
and i've used that analogy for yeah
certainly for creatives
like you know
be curious
be a business development person build
relationships build toward a future
without the urgency without the anxiety
there's no stress in that there's no
need in that now it's just a gift of
genuine curiosity about the other and
not keeping yourself a secret share who
you are and what you do and why you do
it why you care what what was the first
moment when you knew
you you had to have a create you know go
down this path and be a creative
professional
christie dryling yes yes christie's a
dear friend yeah and i found her book
accidentally
somehow and it was really fascinating to
read especially about her upbringing and
she talked about a poverty mindset
and i'm curious how we can all fall into
that trap and maybe not even realize it
yeah well i think it's very common look
i think that we're unfortunately
i i won't say mis-educated i'd say
under-educated i think there are you
know in our system in our culture
there are a lot of
what i consider really
um
essentials that we're simply not they're
not in our curriculum that we're not
taught we're not taught financial
literacy
we're not taught mindset we're not
taught success principles
um
it it it hasn't yet found its way into
the body politic that is our educational
system
and i think that a lot of people do fall
into a poverty mindset they're you know
it's we are
um we are fed a steady diet
through the internet through the classic
traditional media what have you
of of
sensational stories because that's what
sells
and it's often fear-based
uh and fear is powerful medicine and
most people are not immune to it
there's very few people who can see over
that hedgerow and stay centered and stay
present and stay committed to their
vision and their and and what
what's theirs to do
um and we see that you know covid we see
it you know like there's a uniform
response amongst most people
to bad news and we see it all the time
and i think it sort of degrades our
sense of
manifest destiny and our vigor and our
determination
of and belief in what's possible
applying the poverty mindset to
being active
pitching working on projects not giving
up because that poverty mindset can
permeate into other areas it's not just
financial poverty it's also sort of lack
of opportunity
the belief that you can't actually make
something happen doesn't have to
actually mean
monetary value right
so how do we how do we get ourselves out
of that because some people could come
from
some you know a stable middle class
environment or upper middle class they
could probably still possess that
poverty mindset being told maybe you
can't make a career out of this find a
find a stable position where
you know
there's a pension very few jobs still
have pensions but
people often turn away from
what's possible or from actual career
choices because they don't know how
how am i going to make that a reality
and
my understanding of life is it's really
not that important to understand how
what's really important is to understand
what you want
be really clear about what you want and
very clear about why you want it
and at that point the how is you know
like a collaborative effort between you
the universe and seeking out the people
who know the how
they've been down that path
and finding your mentors and finding
your collaborators finding your partners
whatever it might be
but it's if you can't go in with that
clarity that story that's really true
and clear
and persuasive about it mostly to
yourself
if you believe it others will believe it
right that's that's really persuasive
about
what it is that you want why you want it
um and what you're willing to do for it
that you're committed to it
the how just becomes the gap that needs
to be filled in with information in
relationships and that's all available
it's the determination i think a lot of
people
get get stopped before they get in the
game because they don't think it's
possible they think it's too hard they
don't know how
they have all these ideas because
it's easy not to believe in yourself
it's easy to stay in your comfort zone
it's another way of saying it
it's
it takes a certain amount of courage
to step out and do the thing
that
you fear others may judge you for
and by the way that you may fail at
right
so it's easier to be safe and stay in
your comfort zone and not take that risk
but the
but it's really not
because we only have one life
and regret is a terrible terrible thing
questioning yourself is a terrible not
believing in yourself
is
not being willing to take risk and bet
on yourself first
it's like chopping off an arm
you know it's just not a good way to
treat yourself
and and if you surround yourself with no
matter what your background and i
granted it's not an equal playing field
i think all souls are created equal
people are not people's backgrounds and
experiences are so so so different and
um but i think we do have we see so many
examples of it
that kind of courage that makes people
rise above a circumstance say i'm so
committed to this
and no matter what my experience or what
my background i am going to find the
people who are more successful who are
in the
direction i want to move in and i'm
going to go there i'm going to
make them my
target and my compatriots and what have
you my mentors
i think it just you know most people
aren't natural born leaders and they
don't necessarily
i read a book years and years ago called
the slight edge jeff holston i think is
the author
and in that book there was really it's
he talks about habits but the
thing that makes it come to mind is
there's a moment in the book when he
talks about a sociological study that
was done that determined
that by the age of five which i is what
first grade
that by the age of five a child has on
average heard the word no
forty thousand times
and he's hurt that same child heard the
word yes eight thousand times
so literally five times the gravity
holding that belief system that human
being down
as there is a yes energy uplifting or
elevating or thinking oh
these things are more possible for me
and
um
that really stuck obviously it stayed
with me i read that book years and years
ago
because i thought my god the math of
that is really a heavy weight
so i think the one of the keys is surren
really take yourself out of your
the other comfort zone is
don't necessarily settle
for those who are your current tribe or
community or the people you hang with
right
like really make a decision that you're
gonna get with people who are the doers
not the dreamers with the people who
will believe in you not the ones who
will judge you
like really consciously say i deserve
better
and i don't want to say it's like fake
until you make it because i actually
think everyone deserves it but if you're
willing to go after what you think you
can grow into what you deserve increase
your capacity
find the people who are going to say
yeah
we support you we not only don't judge
you we encourage you
what does a successful screenwriting
career look like
well
everyone's going to find it differently
because everyone's needs are different
everyone's psychology is different but
what i would say is anyone who can
survive by focusing the majority of
their energy on getting better at and
deeper anchors inside the film and tv
business
that's success how much you earn
is is you know your
what you need to earn to be successful
and
for example
is it successful for someone to be hard
at work as a writer
while doing a day job at a an agency or
at a production company or at a studio
or the like
i think yes because they're making all
those relationships i mean that's so
important like
if someone's going to have to have a day
job to help support the writing or
supplement what they're earning on the
writing side do it by working in the
business and make relationships because
that's the piece that otherwise is
generally missing
like to me that's a successful model
um
but in terms of earning
yeah you know some people they're
thrilled if they can make 25 000 a year
some people are
only going to be happy if they're making
100 000 or more a year
it's hard to say
but you want to get yourself
um you want you want to earn for your
you want to option projects you want to
sell projects you want to get hired to
do a rewrite
an adaptation whatever those things
might be
and i think that's you know partly what
you should be you know focused on when
you're
spending a lot of your time focusing on
creating the scripts your spec work
but you need to be out there shaking
those trees that's what the
relationships bring you that's the kind
of opportunity that comes in the door if
you are
activist
whether it's through a job or just
reach you know being determined to
expand your network
so it's it's
writing it's doing one job but also
keeping in my mind
i'm going to be looking for other jobs
at the same time because i know this one
is going to pay me soon and then i'm
gonna be out of a job again
it's it's that kind of mindset it's like
um yeah i mean we're all freelancers uh
or many of us
creatives are freelancers and you have
to have that mindset that oh i need
if it's not the most predictable income
then i have to be very activist about
inviting more opportunity in
um
and um
you know i i think it's a game of
numbers it's a game of inches like the
more people that know and that you
articulate you've got to speak it into
the world so you've got to tell a lot of
people
right to get a job you've got to tell a
bunch of people this is what i'm looking
for
i'm looking for adaptations i'm looking
to do rewrites i'm looking for it while
of course i'm writing my specs and i
want to option them i want to sell them
when i get them financed i want to get
them produced but over here
this is the kind of work that i'm
looking for
if you hear of anything
introduce me mention me
right
uh it's going to take some time you
build that up but you build a number and
enough people talking about you aware of
you who've read your work
and think well of you
um
i mean i can give you plenty of examples
and there's a writing team that that you
know one was one was formerly uh is a
producer but very gifted put her
together with another writer uh that
i've worked with in the past
and
all through covet they've been hired
like
i think they're on their fourth project
i'm only one of the four
but i hired them on
on a project and got private financing
to
get them wj minimum so
it's it's finding a support system it's
really putting out into the water you
have to talk about it you have to you
know it's not going to happen
on its own
um
so yeah you're
you've got to be you've got to be your
own best advocate you got to just tell
the world and everybody you me and not
not blather it at starbucks i'm not
talking about that i'm talking about
again being
a little bit more focused than that
well i guess you could do that but yeah
you can you never know you can hold up a
signage starbucks
best piece of advice you've ever
received simple question i realize it
but
i mean it's profound but it's not
profound
um
we talked earlier you know in my in in
my past
uh in san francisco i was a criminal
defense lawyer and it was an absolutely
brilliant experience the people that i
met the things i was exposed to the
community that i served
it you know if if i've often said if our
if our life is a book that was one of
the best chapters i'll ever know
it wasn't necessarily my calling in the
sense that it was a perfect fit for my
temperament
i didn't want to do it into well into my
adulthood but i'm so grateful for it it
taught me a lot
when that came to a close and i knew the
day it came to a close it was i was done
um i was very nervous because
the person i most admire my hero my best
friend was my dad and i had to go now
tell my dad
not just that i was quitting a job but
that i was quitting a career because i
really didn't want to be an attorney
beyond
that choice that i had made
so i went to my dad and we i pulled him
out of his business and we got to go
have a bite or
something a drink
and um
and we sat down at this place and i was
so nervous
what was his reaction going to be and
finally
i said dad you know we're here because
there's something really important i
want to
share with you
he said what is it i said well you know
i'm gonna i'm i'm quitting my job
and i'm quitting the law
it's
not what i want to do
and literally in that moment my father
without missing a beat smiled
something was already wrong
he smiled and he looked at me he said
that's great
and i was just like stunned it was like
i expect parental lecture number what
have you about the investment of time
and money and this is respectable and
all those
typical things
and i and i said dad i just that's not
what i expected
and i actually asked him why why do you
say that why is it great
uh and he said because
i don't think he'd been happy
and i think you should go find what
excites you and whatever that is
i think that's what you should go do
it was like the the utter simplicity
and heart
and humanity of that moment as simple as
that statement was i was just
cowed
it like took me to my knees it was like
oh my god
i know that you're wise i know that
you're an amazing dad
but you've just upped the
game and that's what i would say to
people
and the other is a quote which i'm going
to read because i don't want to get it
wrong it's from i mean after all you
don't want to misquote william faulkner
of all people
so william faulkner had this wonderful
quote that i've always loved always
dream and shoot higher than you know you
can do
don't bother just to be better than your
contemporaries or your predecessors
try to be better than yourself
that's the game
you know it's that like 100-day thing
every day i'm going to wake up i just
want to be 1 better than the me that was
yesterday
were you working for a firm
i was working as a lawyer
it was a foundation
in
in what was the ghetto of san francisco
it was called baby hunters point
so there was the baby hunters point
foundation
that
um
about
125 people
in the center was the sort of linchpin
the sexy sort of fundraising piece which
was criminal defense
so we represented the indigent adults of
that geography in lieu of the public
defender they were ours
and then we had alongside that
we had the the social workers and we had
the
um drug rehabilitation program and we
had the job skills retraining program
and we had all of these the
investigators we had
the idea was a holistic
um solution for this
beautiful community that was very
beleaguered in many ways
keep the families together the kids in
school the guys out of jail etc
and um
our chief counsel
was named richard bancroft
richard bancroft
i was so intimidated by this man when we
first met baso profundo voice tall
good-looking african-american older a
civil rights leader in the south before
lbj coined the phrase civil rights
he'd been a president a national
president of the naacp he'd seen
life that i couldn't even imagine
and he was our chief counsel and then we
had a few attorneys and then a couple of
schlubs like me
but then we had all these other services
these human services to serve this
beautiful community
and for a kid who really had never spent
time in the projects or
in the criminal justice system certainly
it was eye-opening
and it was a perfect it was a perfect
it was a perfect dance it was a perfect
marriage for me at that time
these people became my family they
became my teachers
i learned more in my very first year of
interning for them than i learned in
three years of law school
it was
extraordinary
yeah
they're still there
did you see pursuit of happiness because
that takes place in san francisco
correct yeah yeah yeah
yeah great film great story excellent
yeah extraordinary real story
yeah
yeah it was it was um
you know as they said the best of times
the worst of times
i loved i loved i loved every day that i
spent there
and emotionally
i was a wreck almost every night
yeah that's i wasn't i wasn't built for
criminal defense
i couldn't separate
you know i wasn't a great chess player
i wore it on my sleeve a little bit
sure
yeah
but again it gives you just insane
levels of appreciation for how
diverse
this life experience can be
and
just the unexpected challenges and joys
you know like that was one of the most
joyful communities i've ever experienced
in my life
do you ever go back i'm sure has it been
gentrified by now maybe um
yes and no not really i mean it's it's
it's such a physically
uh it's it's it's literally across the
bridge to get to it you don't go there
unless you mean to go there
so when when i say it's segregated i
mean it like literally physically is
its own distinct area
um out by the old shipyards
um but the truth is i could be wrong
because you know
precious as land is let alone in san
francisco maybe it's been gentrified i
haven't been up you know harlem's been
gentrified maybe maybe a hundred point
been gentrified i haven't been up to see
it in
oh god
i don't know 15 years
or more
yeah
so you had the lunch with your dad
he gave you his blessing so to speak
even though you already had this plan
and then you
gave your notice or you had already
given your notice at that time
um
i had i i had let people know
it wasn't like i walked in
gave my notice and walked out the door
these were family
it was really heart-wrenching for me to
leave
um
[Music]
but yeah i couldn't not
and there were some personal things that
went on that that just made it
impossible for me to be doing that work
um
but it was like uh
yeah you know
when i went to law school i went to
golden gate university law school which
was actually directly across the street
from my dad's place of business and
everybody knew my dad and it was like it
was
just so perfect anyway
my first year of law school i met a gal
who was in my class
she was
probably about my age back then
single mom
two boys
msw degree and a private social work
practice that was hers oh wow
and she was a full-time first year law
student
rosario
her name was rosario
african-american big personality
smart as a whip
and i remember being at first like you
know
i i didn't approach her because she was
like superwoman right how do you have an
msw and two kids and be a full-time law
student and just
how is that
possible well we did become friends
and one day she approached me
um halfway through our first year i
think it was and she said gary you you
know i know you've i hear you've worked
out at baby hunter's point and you know
you're close to the
to them
um
i'd love to
meet them
can i go out there with you sometime and
i said of course absolutely
so i check her out on
every tuesday with staff meeting day
when everybody's there and i said let's
go out on a tuesday y'all you'll meet
everybody
so i took her out
introduced her walked in introduced
everybody schmoozed away you know got
into the staff meeting came out
schmoozed with everybody hung out made
sure she met everybody who was there
and said i loved being there i wasn't in
a hurry to leave anyway finally
it's time to go we got my little karma
gear volkswagen to head back to downtown
san francisco
and drop her off late afternoon
so
suffice to say rosario was not a shy
retiring wallflower she was
she was full of life
we get in my car and i start driving
[Music]
and i've been driving now for several
minutes and she hasn't uttered a
syllable
we come to a red light and i stop
and i look at her
she's looking straight ahead
and i said rosario
is everything okay
you haven't said a word
and privately i never experienced that
right
and she turned and she looked at me and
very slowly
she said
those people
really love you
and it took me a minute for
the dimension of that to sink in right
um
it was it was i think she was a bit
surprised by the dimension of our
relationship
and i say i tell you that i share that
anecdote
really to describe how meaningful that
was to me and how hard it was to leave
them it wasn't hard to leave the
practice of law at all
but it was hard to leave the
people
but i will say this just much like being
a kid in the 60s in san francisco and
being at uc berkeley in the heyday and
putting on the kind you know and then
that experience of baby hunters those
are all
related
in the you know in the daisy chain of my
life
those are all pivotal moments that
really have
everything to do with forming my world
view
how i see things what i care about it
was a extraordinary time i was very
i'm still to this day grateful that i
have the history that i have
yeah pretty cool
pretty blessed
and here we are in hollywood
not bad
excited for
i don't know i think i i think we're at
a really exciting moment
like that
for me
when the studios became
purchased
and you know but then he bought
universal and
sony block columbia et cetera et cetera
et cetera and they became populated with
a different
group of people
um and the budgets went up in the 20
million star and all those things align
with the demise of
the indies
so there's
i don't know 25 or more robust companies
that were putting out as many films just
if not more than the studios
collectively right
um
who were either broken up with their
library value or just went bankrupt or
whatever happened right so the hemdales
and
and and the vestrons and all of those
wonderful companies and
suddenly there was no independent cinema
the studios became more corporate they
made half as many phones with double the
size budgets and
there was this contraction moment
and it was it's a time when i started to
take walkabouts and do other things
alongside
this thing called producing
and suddenly in because of what's
happened in recent years we now have
something that is so much more robust
than that ever was
the demand for story is the
the the size of the appetite and the
number of series and films that are that
are needed and being and actually being
you know be covered aside that
obviously production's been quashed for
the year but but the number of projects
that are being developed and produced
overall
for all of these streamers
who have a lot of diverse appetites to
feed
it's absolutely
stunning to me
and i think it's a great time
to refocus our energies and you know be
in the game and figure out this
this new landscape